welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul definition
aka deathstroke and it's time to put a
smile on that face with some amazing
details that we have about ben affleck's
cancelled batman movie
the project was up in the air for a lot
of time and at one point
affleck pretty much became schrodinger's
bat as we didn't know
whether he was in or out now dc of
course settled on robert battenson
taking over the cape and cowell but with
ben returning for additional scenes in
the snyder cut and
upcoming flash movie i thought we'd take
a look at the original outline
and what we could have got if you
enjoyed the video then please drop a
thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe to the
channel as we do dc videos each and
every week that you definitely
don't want to miss anyway the script
itself had a lot of revisions
and we now know that things pretty much
came to a stalemate with no one behind
the project being 100 happy on the
direction that things were going
we'll discuss someone who read this
script that disagrees with this later in
the video
but clearly there were a lot of issues
affleck was originally supposed to
direct the movie
but he stepped to the side to let matt
reeves take over and not long after the
two parted ways with reeves scrapping
things and
starting again to tell his own story in
an offshoot continuity
all the way back in 2019 robert
richardson the film's cinematographer
confirmed that the script was finished
but not beloved by
anyone on mtv's happy sad confused
podcast
richardson said he'd been hired to film
the movie after he and affleck worked
together on his film lip by night
richardson said there was a lot to do he
was trying to change it
and then he made the decision as you
know to go and do gone girl
according to richardson the movie was
going to take batman to arkham asylum
where he was going to dig into bruce
wayne's insanity and that this would be
used to show the darker side of his
personality
if you've read batman ego then you'll
know that book tackles the dichotomy of
the bruce wayne and batman persona
and the pair pretty much fight one
another in order to take control of the
character's body
richardson stated that the work was
going to delve deeply into the insanity
aspects
and that the project would tackle
questions like who was inside batman
which one was the individual and which
elements of the character were sane and
insane the cinematographer said that
upon entering arkham
he would see an almost black mirror of
everyone that he'd locked up
and how they were in some ways a
reflection of him
now this of course is steeped in several
of batman's villains
like bruce the joker had one bad day
that changed him
but whereas batman turned to the light
joker turned to the dark
the riddler has a genius level intellect
but rather than saving the city
he's chosen to terrorize it two-face
reflects the duality of batman and bruce
wayne
and how they are two sides of the same
coin that seem like polar opposites
penguin was born into a rich family and
though he had a traumatic childhood like
bruce
he instead chose to inflict the
suffering that he'd felt on others
pretty much all of batman's villains in
some ways are aspects of his personality
and we now know that deathstroke was
going to be the main file that the
character was going to be facing off
against
similar to batman he's a master in
martial arts
and the pair facing off against each
other would allow for some incredible
action scenes
joe manginello whose name are probably
pronounced wrong
just don't tell a lad he of course was
playing the villain
and we do know that he actually shot
some additional scenes recently for the
snyder cut
the actor was already featured in the
film for its post-credits scene
but apparently the dialogue that we
originally had under schneider's
direction
was a lot different whereas the
theatrical cut set up the legion of doom
apparently the original version had
deathstroke teasing towards a solo
batman movie
manginello has came out in the last
couple of days and discussed in a lot
more depth
exactly what was going on with the film
when going over the project
he said it was almost going to be like a
david fincher movie
most notably the game it's a film that
you should definitely check out
but just in case you haven't seen it the
movie centers around
a rich and lonely man that slowly sees
his life torn apart by a mysterious
organization
as part of a game i don't want to spoil
it beyond that as i think it's a movie
that deserves to be seen with some
surprises
but batflex movie was apparently going
to have a similar sort of aesthetic
according to the actor deathstroke was
going to strategically tear bruce's life
apart
and slowly he would try and attempt to
send him insane
as he destroyed not only his business
but also his friendships and family
joe stated it was a really dark story in
which deathstroke was like a shark or a
horror movie villain
that was dismantling bruce's life from
the inside out
it was this systemic thing he killed
everyone close to bruce
and destroyed his life to try and make
him suffer because he felt that bruce
was responsible for something that
happened to him
it was really cool really dark and
really hard
that's what she said no but this sounds
absolutely incredible
and i really hope that alfred wasn't in
the lineup of people that died
but who knows you know he's one of the
only people that was close to bruce but
hey
pl please don't kill him it's also very
similar to what we saw an
alternate version of the character dune
to the green arrow in the second season
of that show
so there's definitely precedent here
deathstroke has been known for doing
this sort of thing throughout comic
books
and if you've read teen titans the judas
contract you may remember
that in that he attacked a lot of the
members in their homes
in order to dismantle them when hearing
joe's comments
graphic novels like daredevil born again
by frank miller
also spring to mind miller had the
kingpin discover matt murdock was
the devil of hell's kitchen and from
behind the scenes he destroyed his
relationships
his apartment and made the character
almost take his own life
because he sunk to the very depths of
his sanity both these stories are
absolute classics and you have to check
them out even if you have a passing
interest in the medium
typically when we think of comic book
characters facing off against the forces
of evil
we imagine them in costumes fighting on
rooftops
or at incredible expansive bases however
what these books did is that they
stripped away this idea
and had the villains instead going after
them personally
rather than the persona that they put on
it was something that we hadn't really
seen before
and let's be honest if you're going to
try and kill batman
you wouldn't go after him when he's
dressed up as the dark knight
he'd probably wait until he's in the
queue at mcdonald's or something
and then just walk up behind him and
boom no more batman
though he does seem more like a kfc man
himself which
hey the man's got good taste so seeing
death's stroke go after bruce
rather than batman would add another
dimension to everything
and definitely bring more aspects to the
screen that we haven't seen before
now though we know that most people
behind the scenes weren't too happy with
this script
there's actually someone who read it and
absolutely adored it
in 2018 batman on film put out a tweet
saying that the issue with the film was
that it didn't have a story that affleck
was passionate about
however jay olivier who you may know for
his work on the dark knight returns
fired back saying the following the
original afflex script was the best
batman's script i've ever read
ben had a kick-ass story and i believe
that the audiences and fans
would have loved it now there are rumors
that affleck will be returning for an
hbo max show down the line
that could bring his story to the screen
warner bros seem
enthusiastic about continuing zack
snyder's continuity in some form or
another
and at the weekend it was announced by
scott snyder
that he'd been asked to continue the
story in comic book form
though he didn't have the time to do it
now what tends to happen with things
like this
is that the studio wait until the
following project has been released
and then the original script gets put
out on the internet
what i mean by that is it's likely that
the studio will want to get matt reeves
version released
so that people don't complain about it
not being aflex
and then when the dust settles we'll be
able to see what was
actually going to happen in it i would
have loved to have seen this narrative
continued in some form or another
and i really hope that one day we get to
see what we could have got in an
alternate timeline
affleck remains my favorite batman and i
really hope that after the flash we see
him stick around for a couple more
things
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the movie and if you want to
see ben affleck back for good
the comment section is yours do as you
please
and if you enjoyed this video then make
sure you subscribe to the channel
and check out our breakdown of
everything we know so far about
spider-man 3.
we go over the ins and outs of the cast
list rumors
and what we want to see in the film
don't forget we're giving away three
copies of the lord of the rings 4k box
set and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of december
so make sure you get involved if you
want to support the channel and get to
see content early then please consider
clicking the join button below
you can also come chat is on the discord
server linked in the description or
heavy spoilers on twitter
thanks for making it until the end of
the video you've been the best i've been
paul
i'll see you next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
do
you